weinkönigin gibt es den beruf auch mit
anderen drogen so kux
[Gelächter]
wir machen heute eine schneekugel falls
leute in 30 jahren dieses video noch
schauen schnee nannte man das was vom
himmel fiel vor feuer und wetter aber
nicht drogen nimmt
ich habe sehr schnell holen gekauft okay
geht schneller
ja das stimmt man kann auch wenn man
keine zeit hat und trotzdem was selber
gemacht es mitbringen wieder einfach ein
glas drittel ist so dschungel schnee
kennen sie das kork oder mit was man
denkt und was macht man die pfälzer war
in tetrapacks zu und wichtig für euch
zuhause styropor bekleben und nicht den
deckel direktor sonst würde decken so
heißt das ihr euch eure kleinen internet
finger verbrennen ist es das heißt du
dass ich mich was nicht sagen der neue
ich sei man dann sagen sie es lernen
sind alle total ruhig wusste und sein
schwert ein kreuz ein kreuz
genau das ist was wegen der schweiz aber
das rote kreuz ist ja quadratisch das
wäre dann so wenn jesus so mega kurzen
beine gehabt hätte dann machen wir noch
hier mit einem stöckchen eine freche
burka für das mein sohn ein offenes
visier
sie sind auf dem gegen burka oder ja gut
wäre ich auch nicht aufgegangen
aber gut es gibt einige männer in der
sahara wo ist denn jetzt die grenze für
sie wenn ich jetzt wieviel gesicht soll
ich zu ihr gesicht das man das gesicht
erkennt das habe ich sehr wichtig so
sieht brav aus sieht schön aus aber noch
ein apfel japan märchen herren
[Musik]
es verwirrt mich ja niemand so sehr in
meiner eigenen heterosexualität wie sie
diese also sie und ich leider ist der
das wollen sie jetzt eigentlich sagen
damit ich will damit sagen dass ich
eigentlich auf männer stehe
die alos auf sie und nicht auf markus
söder es war einfach ein kompletter
sagen das aber sehr direkt jetzt das
kompliment für ihre nähe ich wusste erst
überlegen was ihm ein
ich mach mal eine frage herr achselhaare
damit die noch ein bisschen frischer ist
kann man eigentlich feministisch sein
und in der cdu
das ist ja mal richtig frech vokuhila
meinte sie sind mir richtig gute
bastlerin haben sie auch viel gebastelt
das kind ist oft keine messdienerin
werden deshalb was macht man uns
investieren
genau also bei der wandlung brot wein
zum altar tragen das messbuch halten
also man wird schon sehr früh und
alkohol rang getragen der kirche oder ja
ich habe ein buch über bibel und wein
geschrieben also mit den wein in der
bibel
haben sie fehler alibis das ist ja auch
ein ganz beliebter trick für alkohol
können sich einfach eine bibel aus
schnitzen und kein fachmann ran legen
ich bin ja nicht mehr gekauft gefährlich
werden wir können ja noch eine note auf
einmal können sie mich dürfen denn nur
taufe kann jeder christ machen echt und
investierte wasser geht über das so
wenig eine rolle also der heilige geist
sucht sich seinen weg ich glaube bei ihm
kann auch noch lange ich möchte mich
jetzt von ihnen not auf müssen das
machen wir jetzt ja schon was manchmal
eine pflegereform der das skandinavische
modell wird ja sehr oft gelobt gut wenn
man so von ein paar heißen schwedischen
kranke gepflegt wird ist natürlich super
für die männer findet
nicht so gut mal weniger schweden ja
also die finnen finde ich ganz herzlich
die schweden gehen
also ich find ihre differenziert hat
sehr beeindruckt sein
die finnen die schweden ja klar ich
komme aus der straße ich bin
grundsätzlich ja was für andere drogen
geben sie noch außer wein noch
schokolade schokolade esse gerne
schokolade und gummibärchen ohne
gummibärchen geht nicht es gibt auch
weingummi übrigens das ist ja schon mit
karton mit wasser gekocht geschmack
kommen ach so karg ich habe was anderes
was daran sehen dass der schönsten ja
das kann ich jetzt nun wirklich
wiederholen was mach ich richtig versaut
sagte rohles es geht jetzt mit der uci
sie flippte komplett aus so und was
mache ich hier mit das schütten sie auch
einfach mal so viel sie wollen sich
nicht wie sie diese daher danke und dann
noch die gröberen flöckchen das nah dran
an ihm slime kennen sie das wenn sie
nicht wissen wo die haare anfangen der
leyen aufhören jetzt ran langsam dritten
quarter worden oder taufen ist jetzt
auch eine art nottaufe nein nein sie
sind viel besser als ich neuester sind
schnell sterben leute das wird nicht so
nein ich habe mehr so klimakatastrophe
hier sehr furchtbar ich drehe man es
jetzt auch im moment die fünf versuche
wo es nicht geklappt hat schneiden wir
raus wieso kann ich denn das manchmal
richtig zu ich bin ganz nah aber
schneller schneller stellen einmal
schnell haye
also ich finde es auch nicht schön ich
wüsste jetzt auch merken sie seien nicht
wer so was basteln würde ich finde es
grauenhaft
ja aber wenn wir sagen das hätte
immendorff gemacht oder richter oder
sowas so oder einkehr kann mit down
syndrom also wenn man einfach so sagt
ist das zu kraft ist sogar ein hund mit
down syndrom
oder es werden wird man kann nicht über
negative dinge reden explizit wobei
meine these ist ja wenn man über alles
witze machen macht machen kann dann hat
man gar keine diskriminierung weil dann
jeder in der mitte der gesellschaft ist
aber wir können jetzt diese das glas
noch ein bisschen dekorieren damit es
noch schöner aussieht wie kann es ja
auch einfach komplett verhüllen oder
damit man uns ein bisschen widersprechen
ich habe eine piraten schneekugel mit
mainzelmännchen und anbau und vokuhila
gut ich habe ein gespenst gemacht ist
jetzt eher die minimalistische variante
für euch zu hause wenn ihr jemanden habt
den ihr jetzt nicht so mögen könnte ihm
das schenken oder wenn ihr jemand habe
den ihr mögt wohl einfach testen wollt
ob der euch auch mag wenn ihr im blut
behandelt das sind sie das bin ich gut
haare geschnitten
ja soll ich die haare noch immer
ziemlich gut aus ich hab ne geile beine
half die sind doch keine beine der frau
geschenke also an alle mädchen die
irgendwie 12 oder 16 er sowas sind und
german dagegen halten und glauben sie
müssten so aussehen alles quatsch weil
das reicht nämlich auch um karriere zu
machen ja aber auch nur bedingt ich bin
schon lange wende
vielen dank für die schöne bastelstunde
klein kaum noch viel erfolg mit einer
aus sie tun
schönes jahr danke hinaus hat ja jetzt
erst angefangen haben haben wir noch
verkatert überhaupt jemals verkauft oder
machen sie dann weiter mit dem nächsten
gläschen training
[Musik]